[Music]
what's up everyone this is jermaine
now everyone has been dying to get my
grandmother's macaroni and cheese recipe
and guess what this ain't it but
my friends at tasty challenged me to
make a
mac and cheese recipe featuring these
brand new
cheetos flavored mac and cheese you all
excited
i'm excited let's do it but first i'm
going to start with a rough chop on half
of an onion peel
three cloves of garlic and then add them
to the blender
so we're going to blend this until it's
smooth and if it gets like kind of stuck
in there get a little tight
add a little olive oil in there to
loosen it up
so now it's nice and blended there's no
more chunks now before we add this to
our pot we're going to add butter
you want to make sure the butter is
fully melted before you add the
onion and garlic mixture and also be
careful not to burn your butter because
you don't want to burn the butter
okay our butter is melted so now we can
add the mixture
it doesn't look very appetizing but it
smells
delicious put the heat up a little bit
and then we're going to cook
the onions and the garlic so you want
this to go for about another like three
minutes or so
once again stirring it to make sure it
doesn't burn but you just want to cook a
little bit because you don't want raw
onion in there
while our onions are cooking i'm going
to add the noodle to some boiling water
today i'm using elbow macaroni
time for the cheese sauce i'm going to
start with the heavy whipping cream and
add it to my onion mixture
the next and lastly our aged white
cheddar
all right so we're going to let this go
for another like three
four minutes or however long it takes
for it to get nice and smooth
but uh you need to watch it because it
will burn so make sure you're stirring
it gradually
while this cheese is going we're going
to chop up some fresh jalapenos
to kick up the cheesy jalapeno flavor a
couple notches
so we're going to cut this in half and
we are going to spoon
out the seeds and membrane now i do this
because
personally i don't like my butt to be on
fire but if that's your thing
leave them in there more power to you so
now that jalapenos have been scooped out
you know they're a little more mild
uh we're going to give them a fine chop
on there we want the jalapenos to be
evenly distributed through
the jalapeno layer remember your knife
etiquette we don't want you losing any
digits today
all right jalapenos are done cheese is
done
noodles have been drained time for
assembly so first we're going to add our
cheese sauce to our al dente noodles
and then we're going to give it a quick
stir and you want to make sure that you
save
about a cup and a half of your cheese
sauce because that's going to be the
base
for what we pour over top of the tower
i'm adding some more unmelted cheese
because this is going to help
hold together those layers because you
know it's gonna be a tower and it's
gonna be beautiful
give it another stir add a little more
cheese
give it another stir oh baby
if your mac and cheese doesn't look like
this is it really macaroni and cheese i
mean like is it for real
okay so next we're going to distribute
this into our three different bowls for
our three different layers
it's about about four cups so now
everything's been distributed now we're
going to add our seasoning packs
so first we're going to add the flamin
hot we had the smaller packets for the
flaming hot
so i'm going to use two of them then
we're going to add the jalapeno
and now for the jalapenos that we
chopped up earlier
it's looking very cheetoy already
it kind of looks like that cheese dust
that you get stuck on your fingers
and lastly our original cheese flavor
we're going to save half of this packet
for the cheese sauce at the end
okay so now we're going to add the egg
which is another binder that's going to
hold this whole thing together
we're going to put one egg into each
bowl so now we're going to stir this up
look this is
already starting to be flaming hot color
i can't wait to see this thing
that egg is acting as a nice binder to
kind of bring it all together and then
when it cooks up it'll help everything
just
just firm up and stay together our next
step is to add them to
baking pans now each one of these baking
pans have been
greased with butter and they've been
lined with parchment paper that are cut
out to fit in the bottom
you want to make sure these pans are
really really greased because you don't
want the macaroni cheese sticking you
want it just to pop right out
when you add the macaroni in you just
want to flatten it out to make sure it's
filling the bottom of the pan
all right i don't know about y'all but
this looks crazy i can't wait for it to
be done man
so we're going to add some kobe jack
cheese on the top of each one of these
that way when we go to flip it it kind
of locks it in and stays together
you just want to lightly cover the top
of it you don't have to go overboard
got enough cheese in here already so now
we're going to bake these for about 45
minutes on 375. now this one is going to
take longer to cook and these will
probably be done a little
sooner so you may pull these a little
earlier
all right so now for the moment of truth
we're going to flip these bad boys out
and hopefully
you know hopefully it came out right all
right so i'm putting the keg stand
on the top we're going to flip this
thing over hopefully
if i butted this enough it'll just pop
right out
let's see all right this is our first
layer
cheesy jalapeno
[Music]
that thing is perfect now time for the
next one flamin
hot holding form let's take the
parchment paper off of this one cause
it's still there
it's looking good i'm gonna try to put
it on the plate and transfer it over
i'm really glad we put that egg in here
because it might have been over
if we didn't easy does it
whoo all right there we go two layers
down one more to go
smallest one should be a little easier
as you can see boom
there we go that one's out of there now
we're going to slide this on top
all right it's together all right we got
so i should have let this cool off a
little longer it's falling apart right
here on this outside this is one part
hopefully that's the only part that
comes off
it's too much weight it's too much
weight why
kickstand not a good idea
[Music]
so i think we can all agree that that
first attempt
was a disaster i think the issue was
i didn't let it cool long enough so this
time i let it go about
20 30 minutes to cool off so i also
decided to ditch the cake stand that way
we have a little more support
hopefully it's not a catastrophe first
layer
second layer so far so good
okay now time for our final layer yeah
that's
mac and cheese tower so time for the
cheese sauce here goes nothing
oh yeah that is so cheesy so i'm going
to add
some cheetos to the base and then i'm
going to sprinkle some crushed cheetos
all over top to give it a nice little
garnish
this is actually looking pretty cool if
i do say so myself
now for our parsley there it is voila
a cheetos mac and cheese towel
all right let's do this hmm that's
pretty good
it definitely has the jalapeno taste i
think the fresh jalapenos
definitely helped you really got the
cheeto flavor in the cheese i poured on
top
the flamin hot it has like a little kick
towards the back end
not too overwhelming which is good so
this is definitely a upgrade from your
regular
boxed macaroni this thing looks pretty
crazy but i'm
actually pretty happy how it came out
i'm jermaine rawlings and
i'm tired talk to you later oh yes
[Music]
you